bueno
[Música]
que un colombiano que está en el
exterior dice que desde colombia que es
lo que la mayoría de la gente piensa
un día estaba yo pidiendo un número para
ir a una reunión
me recogió un conductor bastante amable
unos 30 años norteamericano hablaba
bastante y me preguntó de dónde era yo
seguramente por mi nombre o porque tenía
acento and from colombia le dije y hubo
un par de segundos de silencio y después
me dijo pablo escobar
es que yo me di narcos
y después me pregunta qué tal es el tema
de la coca en colombia
y yo me quedé mudo
y nos quedamos paralizados de la rabia
de la ira
o algunos respondemos a la defensiva o
con insultos muy agresivos porque no
sabemos qué hacer
y se va formando esta bola de nieve de
frustración de vergüenza y cuando uno ya
cree que la mala imagen que tiene
colombia en el exterior ya es cosa del
pasado
salen plataformas como netflix o alguna
otra película nueva de hollywood que
vuelve y pone el estereotipo colombiano
en los titulares del mundo
de ahí surgió una necesidad mía de
contribuir la colombia pero con
creatividad
porque la fácil y lo típico es que uno
se pone los guantes pero como imaginar
una respuesta positiva y que no la pueda
poner en acción
y cuando digo imaginar y poner algo en
acción me refiero a la creatividad
porque para mí la creatividad es
precisamente es imaginar y luego actuar
y lo que hicimos como publicistas porque
yo trabajo en la industria de la
publicidad tenemos esta habilidad de
agarrar un concepto agarrar otro
concepto juntarlos y formar uno
completamente nuevo y una habilidad que
yo tengo que soy muy agradecido con la
vida por tenerla es que me encanta
juntar y conectar gente que ve el arte
la literatura la música la publicidad y
no lo ven como un trabajo sino como una
forma de vida
y junto a este grupo de personas
maravillosas a imaginar
y luego a ejecutar y nos pusimos a
pensar bueno pero qué hacemos hacemos
qué tal un hashtag o una camiseta con un
logo qué tal si armamos un evento con
grupos o qué hacemos componemos una
canción y empezamos a ver que todo este
tipo de cosas ya habían muchas pues ya
están hechas o la gente ya no de
parábolas
sea lo que sea lo que hicimos al
principio fue ok identifiquemos cuál es
la habilidad qué es lo que nos hace cuál
es ese talento que nos hace únicos
explotemos lo y llevemos a cabo una idea
y nosotros teníamos en ese grupo una
habilidad para escribir comerciales de
televisión para diseñar avisos de
publicidad y algunos también para
escribir películas y de ahí nació una
idea la emboscada colombiana
la emboscada colombiana es el título
pero qué idea hay detrás de esto dijimos
qué tal si usamos el estereotipo
colombiano
para ayudar a combatir el estereotipo
colombiano y suena como una
contradicción pero era una premisa muy
interesante para nosotros seguimos ok
porque las audiencias en eeuu están
acostumbradas a ver ese es el
estereotipo qué tal si atacamos entre
comillas desde adentro
bueno y como lo vamos a ejecutar pues
nos asociamos con simon brand que es un
director colombiano muy talentoso que en
eeuu que también tiene llevar ese sentir
de la patria y ese dolor cada vez que
habla mal de colombia y nos asociamos
con él para lanzar un show
y la idea era vamos a hacer creer a las
audiencias norteamericanas que era una
nueva serie de narcos
y cada vez que se metían a ver los
episodios los embosca vamos con datos
positivos de nuestro país es decir los
sorprendimos con cosas que no tenían ni
idea que tenía colombia porque están
acostumbrados a ver todo lo que lo único
que ven sobre colombia es lo que veían
en netflix y en hollywood
hablamos de la literatura del arte de la
música de la flora y de la fauna de
colombia datos positivos nada de drama
nada de negativismo las mujeres que
están liderando industrias en todo el
mundo que son colombianas
y les voy a mostrar un vídeo de una de
las escenas pero antes quisiera
explicarles uno con mis propias palabras
entonces imagínense a este este tipo
sentado en un escritorio de un estudio
que parece de una hacienda
entran dos sujetos al estudio
a verse con este señor que parece un
patrón y dijo patrón porque la luz el
color la música como están vestidos los
personajes todos estos códigos los vamos
metiendo en la cabeza y ahí es donde
armamos hasta los mismos colombianos el
estereotipo colombiano
y los tipos le ponen una maleta al
patrón en el escritorio el patrón abre
la maleta y en el maletín lo mira mira
los sujetos mira el maletín como un poco
como con con rabia y mira los tipos y
les dice
y la hojarasca
entonces en ese momento dentro de ese
contexto narcos
los tipos empiezan a sostener una
conversación intelectual sobre la obra
de gabriel garcía márquez
y revelamos dentro del maletín que no
había ni drogas ni armas ni nada ilegal
eran libros de gabo
pero los tipos dice patrón con su
permiso pero le trajimos el coronel no
tiene quien le escriba y 100 años de
soledad que es catalogada como una de
las obras maestras de la literatura
hispana del siglo 20 y gracias a la
maestría en sus palabras le ayudó a
gabriel garcía márquez ganarse el premio
de la literatura el nobel de literatura
en 1982 o sea una conversación que uno
se imaginaría que estos sujetos tendrían
y cerramos el mensaje con la frase con
nuestra idea estamos usando el
estereotipo para terminar el estereotipo
y me encantaría mostrarles uno de los
vídeos para que vean ya el producto
finalizado y es algo que lanzamos en
todas partes empezando en eeuu y luego
les cuento más o menos después de que
vean el vídeo cómo se contagió esta idea
entre los colombianos vamos a ver
pero está seguro que lo ha visto por
aquí
porque donde se nos vuelve otra vez
tranquilo papi que yo le quitaba el ojo
encima
[Aplausos]
hoy el patrón todo en orden
está
[Música]
i
ahí está
villar
qué belleza
tienen a pensar que nos vamos a
encontrar por aquí aspiran
[Música]
y las cosas de la familia de los
cardenales
por ser informe
hay quien lo ve
el pecho rígido
todo bien parado todo orgulloso
y los barros saladas
blanquita y nítidas
sabías que es una de las más de 1900
especies de pájaros que en colombia
el pir angle eucop heras
qué galán
[Música]
como dato curioso aldemar correa que es
uno de los actores que sale ahí tenía
que haber dicho paseriforme dijo para
ser informe
si lo notaron ahí ya quedo
enmarcado en esa película
esto tuvo una repercusión la idea
principal el objetivo principal del
proyecto de nuestra nuestra campaña era
llegarle a las audiencias
norteamericanas con algo positivo en
buscarlos por eso se llamó la emboscada
colombiana pero no se imaginan la
cantidad de colombianos que viven en
colombia que empezaron a contagiarse de
esta idea y de pasarla y la pasaron en
sus redes sociales en facebook en
instagram yo recibí la idea a través de
whatsapp no sé cuántos de aquí tengan
familiares en el exterior y la típica es
que tenemos un grupo de whatsapp donde
nos compartimos todos los mimos y todas
las cosas que salen y todas las fotos a
mí me llegó a través de una tía la
campaña
y eso es lo que la creatividad es y por
eso quería
hablar sobre una frase que tenía albert
einstein
y él dice que la creatividad es
contagiosa que hay que pasarla
y esta idea que hicimos es eso queremos
que se contagie y que se pase de
colombiano a colombiano y eso fue lo que
pasó
era una cosa que era nuestra que la
desarrollamos a través de ese talento
que nosotros pensamos que era único
y no queríamos hacer lo mismo que hacían
otras personas
y es la invitación que yo tengo porque
todos tenemos un talento único
todos tenemos una habilidad que podemos
explotar para hacer algo positivo y
contribuir la colombiana todos podemos
imaginar una idea y la podemos movilizar
y la idea de movilizarse que yo les
traigo es movilizar el intelecto
movilizar el corazón y usar la
creatividad para contribuir y cambiar la
imagen de colombia en este caso ese eso
era mi sentir y es ahora lo que yo
quería hacer hay muchas formas de
ayudarle a colombia pero encontremos ese
talento único y encontremos una razón
nosotros nos hicimos dos preguntas antes
de arrancar con este proyecto
la primera era cuáles son nuestras
razones para hacer
y una razón muy personal mía en realidad
son tres razones son mis hijos emma luca
y benjamín
y todos tenemos una razón diferente
y la segunda pregunta que nos hicimos
fue
qué es lo que sabemos hacer que nadie
más en el mundo sabe hacer puede que no
seamos tan especiales pero hay algo que
nos hace únicos y únicos y podemos
desarrollarlo para realmente usar la
creatividad y cambiar un comportamiento
dentro de una sociedad en este caso como
lo hicimos nosotros
las audiencias norteamericanas que están
acostumbradas a conocer de colombia solo
su estereotipo
entonces la invitación me da es
encuentren ese talento único y cuando lo
descubran dos cosas imaginen y actúen
muchas gracias